am I the only person who feels like they
are in a 20th century loop
despite being firmly in 2020 we seem to
be going back a hundred years when it
comes to recognizing creative talent
time and time again there is an
overwhelming alright of diversity in the
nominations our award shows leading to
outrage and head-scratching
but a complete absence of change well
this week it was the turn of the Brits
to deliver a diversity deficit an ignore
female talent in the music industry from
the Oscars to the BAFTAs all these award
ceremonies are now starting to be a
source of confusion which sadly
distracts from the celebration to give
the Brits credit they responded swiftly
when they were called out a few years
ago for their lack of ethnic
representation it worked and there was a
marked improvement the same effort needs
to be applied for gender and other
underrepresented groups this has to be
addressed because the lack of inclusion
undermines and diminishes these
prestigious awards and the talented
individuals who win them without
diversity in music you devalue the sound
I don't think any awards ceremony should
have anything to do with diversity it
should be to do with understand I'm
talking about gender don't ELISA - okay
so please don't it my gender does what
it should be about is outstanding talent
the best of the best and maybe just
maybe this year it seems hard maybe for
you to comprehend that maybe the guys
produce the most stuff this year life
isn't about 50/50 equality the world is
in 1550 equal and now that our music in
the art and I think any attempt to
influence the awards based on gender you
demean the awards themselves and you
demean the artists might make you feel
better June but actually if I was a
female artist the Brits and I got given
an award because I was a woman I would
feel patronized and I'd feel horribly
humiliated as well a guy called Jeff
Taylor who AM is in charge he's their
CEO the bit here a de Kaleo ver hauled
the Academy this year and he made it
50/50
he made fifty percent male fifty percent
female and 24 percent beer me you can't
get more equal than that and you you
have to respect the choice that those
people made their decisions let's just
pass the vanity between 2008 and 2018
there was the zero percent increase in
the number of female acts credited on
the best-selling hundred songs of the
year
conversely between the same period
fifty-four percent increase for the guys
so the guys were producing the more
outstanding work this year what's the
problem with that okay we have it like
quote from Jeff Taylor so watching a few
years ago we changed the makeup of our
voting academy and we radically
overhauled it and so it's 50/50 male
female and we have about 24% BMI
representation on the academy because we
want the Academy to represent the
country but I think we have to respect
the views of those Academy members it is
an equal number of men and women that
have made that choice and I think we
should respect the albums that they've
nominated as being fantastic albums
isn't a problem for you I mean that they
actually have got 50% men and women who
are deciding this and they
disproportionately chose the men this
year well what I would say to that is
perhaps then we need to take one step we
need to go one step further which is
looking at why that happens we didn't
shout about about gender diversity when
Adele wouldn't for Britain worn out we
didn't shout about it when she won six
Grammys in one night or Beyonce what we
did shirt was these people are
screamingly outside outstanding that
aventure problem but their gender had
nothing to do nothing why do they have
to do so well standing so you we can't
have an award season now can we without
the obligatory
race throughout all gender race it's
either/or and then it's because we've
got an identity obsessed politics what
are you suggesting we have quotas there
got to be is that what you'll say so
they think eat called up the jury Half
Men half women
quarter percent beer me and still you
haven't got the result you want well
what have you got to do say they've got
up quotas that's what you appear to be
I'm saying
has got brilliant answers so will you
grab after our now after this year's
awards which take a lot of criticism for
including His Royal Highness
they are looking at changing the process
and I think someone remembered after and
it was vice know something that's there
never look again at how do they how do
the votes happen yep and I suspect what
will come out of it is that they'll drop
a shortlist
mm-hmm something there be it's much
smaller drop a shortlist and then that
shortlist will be give them to the
members but I also suspect when you look
at the shortlist is actually the women
in here although no series our suggests
it's always seem like oh that's one song
I quite like June I don't think it's an
award winner but the day you say
mediocre people win awards just to make
up know people win awards anyway and
whether the person is black or white
male or female that's what should win I
found it very strange at the BAFTAs one
of the very most surreal moments of that
moment was that we had we had a
unelected taxpayer-funded Crown Prince
talking about inclusive inclusivity and
drive around it curious because of
course part of the very nature of the
institution that he represents survives
or not having inclusion and in in for
people that aren't members of the royal
family are born into it or luckily
picked enough to marry one of them but
it's a very gone now yeah we take this
because actually where I'm taking is
that I think there's a bit of us
sometimes in the industry itself there's
a bit of a cognitive dissonance
we're not thinking consistently around
all of this and so you know if you're
gonna if you're gonna champion diversity
and inclusion for one organization and
sure sure you know
as well the most interesting the study I
saw this week from the Blitz it was new
gov and someone said to what extent are
Britons interested in finding out war
who won at the BRIT Awards and it turned
out 80% didn't give a tough something to
read from men Oh Mabel says as women we
get molded into something that we don't
necessarily want to be where is there's
a boy I think you encouraged to just
sort of figure it out and do whatever
you want to do I think it's about
encouraging young female artists to give
them the space to experiment I can I
just say I love the way that storms he
accepted his award in that he also
celebrated the women behind him like
Akua who've made his success possible